la règle c'est qu'il n'y a pas de règle
on n'est pas là pour les sentiments on
est là pour tirer un bon copain viens de
me marier disais que je me trompais avec
mon smartphone ya tellement de filles
qui se font passer pour des petites
vierge alors qu'en vrai ce sont de gros
scotch tous les quatre ans non il ne
reste plus qu'une jeu court et moi je
fais quoi
mais quelle galère jamais on me dit que
ça va être aussi dur
si je t'assure qu'il sait bien ce que
disent la plupart des gens ce que c'est
un bébé strict guerrier c'est la journée
sans bébé aujourd'hui intérim moi parce
que je suis vierge mais jamais vous
m'entendrez dire le gars avec qui j'ai
couché hier m'a pas rappelée aux options
deux ans à tort la scène j'ai eu aucune
relation avec un my depuis un an c'est
trop demandé d'arriver à sortir avec un
autre mec que celui qui ment grossi au
les canons qui salut je m'appelle
nicolas alors tu es en train de me
draguer c'est ce que tu fais c'est toi
qui me rock frais d'intérêts niveau on
aura dix statues grecques tellement ils
étaient quatre en non dit pas ça ils ont
une toute petite quéquette vol sergueï
est au téléphone avec son ex son gosse à
la dia et je rêve c'est ma première
sortie depuis la naissance du pied
il veut ma peau de bébé là et les gosses
qu'est-ce qui nous emmerde
j'ai eu honte de dire que j'étais maire
j'ai menti uniquement pour draguer en
heck
je suis devenu une idiote qui se relie
pour un peu de tendresse
c'est un fameux ce colloque qui est un
bébé exactement je t'imagine grave avec
un ghost est fait pour être mère et vous
avec votre moustache je vous imagine
gravant détraqué sexuel
j'y tiens ce mec est là maintenant on
n'est plus dans les petits mensonges en
hauteur on est dans le bas rhin pas su
perino
c
samantha que nos jours les gens fassent
des gosses alors qu'il ya tellement
qu'un chien qui sont à la rue si tu
ressembles à une prostituée ou à
jennifer aniston en fanless mali tu as
vu portier de nuit qui sort avec marie
même statut et le colonel moutarde avec
un champ de riz vous êtes vraiment
lourde